hi welcome to Uncle Tim's Farm I'm Uncle
Tim and in today's episode I'm going to
be working on the footing for the feeder
pigs around their feeder and yeah I'm
going to be putting down some mulch it's
going to take a lot because that mud's
really deep this way it'll make it much
easier for them to stand there and fill
their bellies up
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
well that's 13 bags so that should about
do it we'll see how well this holds up
but it sure made it a lot better
foreign
looks like the pigs are enjoying it
that'll make it much easier for them to
stand there at the feeder and fill their
bellies
it was a neat muddy mess but this is
much much better for them thanks for
watching come back again next time and
don't forget to subscribe see ya
[Music]
foreign